[Music]
yeah welcome back to Sweetwater secrets
I'm your host Liana Galera and I've
missed all of my fellow river babes so
much Oh okay guys I hope you've had a
lovely winter break and a fabulous new
year you know it has been 35 days since
our last new episode of Riverdale and I
don't know about you but I'm more than
ready to reunite with Archie Veronica
Betty Jughead and all the rest of our
rows Riverdale residents and this week's
midseason premiere episode 210 chapter
23 the Blackboard Jungle yes the
serpents are coming to Riverdale high
and I'm so pumped now today's Sweetwater
Secrets is a little special so first I'm
gonna be taking a look at some of your
comments about the midseason finale
chapter 22 Silent Night deadly night and
you had so much to say and then we're
gonna launch into a special hisses and
kisses about all of season 2 so far so
start shouting out the things that
you're absolutely loving and hating
about all of season 2 in the comments
below and I might read your hisses and
kisses live in just a little bit cuz yes
for all you early birds who are tuning
in right now we are live thank you for
joining me
but let's kick things off with the fact
that the black hood was supposedly
revealed in the last episode and it was
creepy janitor Svendsen lame oh my
goodness you guys I cannot tell you how
frustrated I was that after ten episodes
of who is it who was under this hood
it's this random character that they
introduced like two episodes beforehand
I was really bummed about this and I
know you guys were really frustrated
about it too so here are some of your
comments for what you had to say so come
on over okay
so first up Haley Alexis said am I the
only one who thinks the black hood isn't
dead no you are not girl I had mentioned
it in our lastly order secrets episode
that I do not think this fencin was
really
the person under the hood and you guys
all agreed as well
Dominique Bryant said janitor Conway was
not black hood black hood framed an
innocent man for murder just like Conway
did see black hood is getting rid of
people that sinned black hood is still
alive
and by the way Archie and bug head
shippers like this comment anyone else
like my theory I like your theory
I like those ships moving on Riverdale
fan 101 had a great point they said I'm
a bit confused now is Betty gonna become
her own version of the black hood and I
have to say I'm not really buying the
story of the janitor being the hooded
vigilante either way I can't wait for
the next episode I can't wait either
especially because I cannot wait for us
to discuss the other gigantic moment
that happened in the midseason finale
the barchi kiss yes that is right Betty
and Archie shared some really sweet
moments together you know they had that
holiday gift exchange and then we saw
them kiss in the car and a lot of you
had things to say about this some of
them were good some of them were bad but
here's what you guys really had to say
about it so first off juju beans said
major hisses - that barchi moment I'm
sorry but I'm not buying whatever the
writers are trying to plot this was a
rebound for both because they both got
their feelings hurt but I'm excited for
Sheryl to be the one to expose the
barchi kiss because let's be honest our
creepy girl needs to have her moment yes
juju beans also added another hiss to
the writers of the show first we want
more Kevin and Sheryl preach second stop
making Archaea ho
okay I don't know about the phrase in
there but I will say Archie has been a
little flighty this year and we'll get
more to that in our hisses and kisses
Sarris sullivan said I love barchi
please don't hate me
we don't hate you you can ship whoever
you want if you like barchi and want
them to be endgame awesome we will find
out deke Elmer said kisses to the barchi
kiss I'm actually prober Annika but
since I doubt it'll ever happen barchi
is second best Hey Never Say Never
bronica is awesome as well and that
trashy fangirl said first off half his
half kiss to the barchi kiss I love
barchi but I think they should wait long
to be together I've always loved them in
the comments and I hope they are endgame
um
Deanna wag said I don't care if no one
ships Jar Qi but I do
as in Jughead and Archie that's amazing
DISA Shah said am I the only one who
wants Jughead and Veronica to be
together because they would be so cute I
don't know about that combination I've
never really thought about it but
everyone on the show is attractive so it
really doesn't matter who's paired
together actually yes it does
um which leads me to Octavia black who
goes I don't know who to ship follow
your heart
Octavia follow your heart into Riverdale
and just live there and just see who
resonates with you as a couple but we're
moving back on over here let's talk
about season 2 as a whole there is a ton
of hisses and kisses you guys have been
so vocal this year but here's who I
really want to talk about right now so
first up in hisses all right guys my
first major hiss goes to the black hood
you guys we have spent ten episodes
fixating on who this person is yes at
the beginning I really did care because
they shot Fred and honestly this was
it's something that disrupted the entire
town we were all on this big witch hunt
we were with Archie as he was trying to
figure this out but truly it just got
dragged on a little too long and the
fact that I think that it's not over is
just incredibly frustrating me to me so
hisses to that I'm not really here for
the black hood right now another kiss
right now is to Archie I'm so sorry
I love KJ Appa so much but to me Archie
the season has been kind of out of
character he's been hot and cold he's
been so obsessed with finding the black
hood he went on to this whole tirade
where he had a gun and I just felt like
this was not almost sloppy writing but
like it's like honestly the writers just
didn't know what to do with Archie this
season he had a lot of mood sweetens I'm
not sure what that is the next thing
that I was a little bothered by and I'm
given his two is Betty's striptease once
again Lily Reinhardt looked amahzing I
am not dissing Lily she looks amazing
she can do whatever she wants I'm just
saying the Betty is a sixteen-year-old
girl she was in a room full of adult men
strutting around I understand that it's
like serpent tradition and she was just
trying to fit in with the gang but still
I was really irked out about that right
now
another hiss is going straight to penny
Peabody yes she is a good foe in my
opinion adding in this new character
took time away from Josie and Kevin and
Cheryl and a lot of the other characters
that I would like to get to know even
more I feel like I know more about penny
Peabody than I do about Kevin Keller
right now and I'm not okay with that and
of course another hiss is going straight
out to all of the bug head drama
goodness gracious this couple has been
up and down faster than a yo-yo what is
their deal
I love whenever we get to see those
heartfelt bug head moments because lily
and Cole have such great chemistry
together that's obvious and when they're
on they are fantastic but when they're
just randomly trying to break them up
and bring them back together and throw
random people in between them that's
what really bothers me moving on to our
kisses let's talk about happy things is
I want to give this kiss straight to
Tony topaz in my opinion she is the best
new edition of season 2 now of course
we're all little hesitant at first
because she initially came in as almost
a foe to the bug-head fandom but I feel
like she's really proved that she can be
a great friend to Jughead and the fact
that she's giving us a female
perspective of the south side serpents I
really AM enjoyed and seeing that plus I
just think that Vanessa Morgan the
actress that plays here is so incredibly
kicked butt and I adore her another kiss
is going out to the fact that Veronica
and Archie y'all got the hots for each
other and I'm not mad at it I think that
they were our top couple not in terms of
how I feel about them but just in terms
of seven seconds in heaven alone they
had the most affection by far in season
two
they've been kissing all over the place
and you cannot deny that cami and KJ
have some serious chemistry so whatever
they're doing keep it up because it's
just nice to see another kiss is going
straight out to F P and in fact all the
parents right now
I think it's been so great that we've
been incorporating more of the parents
into the storylines in nice organic ways
for example when FP is getting out of
jail I really like to see the evolution
of his relationship with Jughead you
know it was so strained in season 1 and
now we're gonna start to see that father
son bond through the Serpent's really
loving all of that and of course you all
know that I'm here for Alice Cooper she
can do no wrong in my eyes truly I think
that she's the best parent on the show
but I would like to see more from Fred
when my last kiss is going straight out
to Cheryl blossom girl that is for you
all hail the Queen girl it doesn't
matter if she's obsessed with Josie she
can do no wrong in my mind this was a
particularly creepy scene but truly I
just feel like Cheryl is the catch-all
for crazy in the show in the best way
possible Madeleine Pech brings it in
every scene that she's in and honestly I
just think that she's a fantastic
character and we're getting so many
comments from you guys there are a lot
of kisses for the barchi kiss so I think
that's fantastic that you guys are so
excited that more couples are getting a
little bit of love on the show let's see
we've got right here Selene says finally
Sweetwater secrets is back yay thanks
Celine you know the sweetest Tessa says
bug head I can't wait for the new
episode if you're a bug head fan I'm not
sure you're gonna like tonight's episode
necessarily but tune into the after show
because we'll be discussing all of it at
a says the barchi kiss with a heart eye
emoji yes girl
Kayla says kisses for bug head and
hisses at the black hood reveal I
completely agree Holly says kisses to
Alice Cooper just being a queen yes
every time that we get a little bit more
of her serpent past is one of my
all-time favorite moments of the show
Alyssa says kisses to Alice Cooper and
Veronica saying I love you to Archie I
thought that was really sweet and I
liked the fact they took their time with
having Veronica say I love you it's a
big thing to say to someone so I thought
it was really nice that Riverdale took
the time to show that it's a big step in
a relationship we also have Abby who
says I want to see jellybean girl I
agree I want to see jellybean - I asked
Cole about it I'll continue to ask ho
about it because we need jellybean
autumn says hisses - not enough Sherrill
I agree and not enough Kevin and not
enough Josie and Reggie for that matter
I thought he's been a really great
addition this year and I think that we
need to see more of him Lulu says his
Mysti barchi slash bug head break up and
the black hood reveal kisses - VAR qi
getting back together and all the bug
head scenes in the whole show I will
agree I love the bike head scenes just
because I think that they have a really
sweet chemistry together and I want to
see more of that I'm just bummed that
they keep giving us this back and forth
moment between them let's figure it out
Bridget says Cheryl slays I completely
agree
you guys are sending in so many amazing
comments I'm loving all of this right
now
Audrey on Twitter had said Riverdale is
back tonight very excited to see Cheryl
ruined some lives funny you should say
that because as we know Cheryl happened
to catch the barchi kiss from her
bedroom window and I don't know that
could be something that comes up in
tonight's episode also Amy says I think
Alison FP should get more flashbacks oh
I agree
and I'm really excited for you guys to
watch the Sweetwater Secrets after-show
because I drop a major theory that I
think that you guys are gonna really
like and it involves FP and Alice I
might be crazy I don't know but I need
you guys to tune into the after show so
that you can tell me what you think
another thing that I really love is
Lauren from Twitter says this whole
season except bug-head kisses has been a
hiss line someone's a bug head fan and I
respect it honestly guys I love all the
ships on the show I think that every
couple there's the myth I think that
there's validity for you to ship any
couple on the show and there's no right
or wrong answer truly so I just love
that we're all fans of Riverdale and
just to remember to be kind to each
other on Twitter just because they might
not like your ship doesn't mean that
their opinion is wrong it's just they
don't share the same opinions yours and
of course be sure to be nice to all the
actors who are playing the characters
that you love on Riverdale they're not
the writers they don't control what
happens to their characters so of course
just remember kindness is key now I'll
give you guys just a couple more teases
about tonight's episode
so these serpents are coming to
Southside hi or excuse me the serpents
are coming to Riverdale high South Side
High has been mysteriously closed and of
course having all these kids under one
roof proves too
a lot of delicious chaos that you guys
are going to love there are some
questions that are going to be answered
and some questions that are going to be
completely ignored and we will of course
be discussing that all on Sweetwater
secrets after-show but that does it for
this week's live preview of Sweetwater
secrets now you guys tune in after you
watch episode 210 because I have got
exclusive details from Lilly Reinhardt
about the Cooper family's newest
addition and you don't want to miss it
because so much happens with the
Cooper's tonight now if you've had fun
with me on this video or just can't get
enough Riverdale please give this video
a like and share Sweetwater secrets with
your friends and you can come chat with
me on Twitter any time about what you'd
like to see on the next episode of
Sweetwater thank you guys so much for
tuning in as always I'm Liana Galera and
I'll talk to you soon bye river babes
[Music]
you
you